Have you ever paused and noticed
something truly peculiar about
how we perceive events,
especially in the news?
Like 2 situations almost
identical in their core physical
actions can somehow land in our
minds with drastically, even
wildly different impacts.
Yeah, it's strange, isn't it?
It's as if the story woven
around in action becomes far
more potent, shaping our
understanding and our emotional
response more than the raw
action itself.
Exactly.
Think about something as
seemingly simple as a city
cleaning up a public space.
On paper, it's just sanitation,
right?
Sweeping streets, maybe moving
some things along.
But depending on who is doing
it, why it's being done, and
most crucially, how it's being
talked about, that simple act
can transform into something
else entirely in our collective
consciousness.
A triumph, a heavy-handed
crackdown, or even, you know, a
cynical performance.
The meaning totally shift.
Today, in the Deep Dive, we are
plunging head first into that
very phenomenon, the concept of
framing.
It's not just about what
happens, but how that happening
is packaged, presented, and spun
to deliberately shape our
perception.
It's the unique lens through
which we, the audience, are
encouraged to see things, often
without even realizing it.
And this isn't some abstract
academic theory.
It's a powerful everyday force.
It absolutely influences our
opinions, our understanding of
leaders, and ultimately our
whole political landscape.
And at the very heart of this
discussion, guiding our
exploration, is a profound
observation from the renowned
Republican pollster Frank Luntz.
He once distilled the core truth
of modern political
communication into a single,
incredibly potent line that
resonates far beyond partisan
politics.
Yeah, it's not.
What you say is what people
hear.
That quote is so key and it's
important to understand what he
meant by that.
He wasn't talking about some
kind of mystical subjective
interpretation where everyone
just hears whatever they want.
No, not at all.
It's pointing to a very
practical, often deliberate
reality.
The actual meaning and emotional
weight an audience takes away
from a statement or an action
can diverge significantly from
the literal words spoken or the
physical act performed.
Right.
It's about the resonance, the
underlying implications, maybe
the historical associations and
the emotional triggers that get
activated in the mind of the
receiver.
Sometimes that's completely
irrespective of the speaker's
literal intent.
OK, let's really unpack this
because it's absolutely critical
for any well informed.
Citizen rank, Absolutely.
Our mission today is to dissect
2 recent real world examples
where political leaders
undertook actions that were,
from an operational standpoint,
strikingly similar.
Yet the media coverage, and
consequently the public
discourse surrounding them,
frame these actions in radically
different ways.
And just to be clear, we're not
here to pass moral judgment on
the actions themselves.
That's a whole different, albeit
important, conversation.
Exactly.
Instead, our focus is purely on
the mechanics.
Yeah.
How narratives are built, how
they travel, how they're
consumed, and what that tells us
about understanding the often
complex, sometimes contradictory
stories around the actions in
our interconnected world.
It's about equipping you, the
listener, with the tools to see
past the headlines and
understand the underlying
dynamics of public perception.
It's truly fascinating how
Luntz's principle of what people
hear become so vividly apparent
when politicians carry out these
operationally similar actions.
You see it playing out across
the entire political spectrum,
don't you?
Whether it involves clearing
homeless encampments, increasing
police presence in urban areas,
or implementing large scale
public works.
The fiscal concrete actions
might share remarkable
commonalities.
But the narratives that are then
spun around them by various
media outlets, by political
allies, by vocal critics, can be
so divergent that they almost
describe entirely different
realities for the public.
And that's precisely where the
profound power of framing and
its ability to shape our
collective imagination truly
becomes evident.
The broom, as it were, is
wielded in different hands, and
suddenly it's no longer just a
cleaning tool.
It becomes a symbol of something
else entirely.
That's a crucial distinction,
and to really bring this concept
to life, we're going to delve
into two distinct case studies,
starting with what we've
playfully but pointedly dubbed
the Governor's Broom in San
Francisco.
This event unfolded not too long
ago, in November of 2023.
Ah yes, the APEC summit
preparation.
Exactly.
San Francisco, known for its
vibrant culture but also it's
very visible urban challenges,
underwent what can only be
described as an extraordinarily
rapid and comprehensive cleanup
of its urban core.
Anyone who lived there or even
visited would have noticed it
immediately.
Streets that had long seen a
certain level of, let's say,
disorder, were suddenly visibly
pristine.
But why such an intensive
citywide effort seemingly
overnight?
Well, as you said, it was all in
preparation for the Asia Pacific
Economic Cooperation or APEX
Summit.
Now for many of our listeners
who follow global affairs,
you'll know APEC is a high level
annual meeting.
It brings together leaders from
countries across the Pacific
Rim, representing a huge chunk
of the global economy.
But what made this particular
summit in San Francisco truly
stand out, elevating its profile
to an unprecedented level, was
the attendance of Chinese
President Xi Jinping, right.
His presence transformed APEC
from just a significant Economic
Forum into a deeply symbolic,
high stakes international event.
Suddenly the eyes of the world,
or at least a very powerful
segment of it, we're going to be
fixed directly on San Francisco.
So the pressure was on.
Immense pressure and the city's
response in terms of practical
action was indeed extensive and
highly visible.
City workers, often working
around the clock, were deployed
on mass.
Doing what primarily?
Their primary task was the
removal of homeless encampments,
which, as you mentioned, were
widely known as dense clusters
of tents, makeshift shelters and
personal belongings that had
become a very visible and often
challenging part of the cities
urban landscape.
OK.
So clearing those areas.
Exactly beyond that, the
aesthetic improvements were
meticulous.
Graffiti, which had long adorned
many public surfaces, was
methodically scrubbed clean.
Sidewalks in areas frequented by
the visiting dignitaries, the
designated routes for
motorcades, the vicinity of
conference venues, places like
Moscone Center, Union Square,
parts of the Embarcadero were
not just swept, but thoroughly
power wash.
Power wash.
Wow.
Yeah, it gave them an almost
unnaturally pristine appearance.
It was without a doubt a
concerted, highly strategic
effort to transform the city's
public for this extraordinarily
important international
gathering.
Every detail seemed aimed at
presenting San Francisco as
clean, orderly and globally
sophisticated.
What?
Makes this case so remarkably
insightful.
Almost serving as a baseline for
understanding transparent
framing was the refreshingly
direct candor from Governor
Gavin Newsom.
Yeah.
That was interesting.
Newsom, a Democrat who not only
serves as California's governor
but also previously held the
office of mayor of San
Francisco.
Right, he knows.
The city, Well, he.
Didn't attempt to obscure the
motive or concoct some elaborate
story about the timing of this
massive cleanup being a mere
coincidence.
He was incredibly
straightforward.
Almost disarmingly so.
Well, he explicitly and quite
memorably compared the entire
cleanup operation to something
we can all relate to.
Cleaning your house before
guests arrive.
That analogy really hits home,
doesn't it?
Instantly.
It communicates the explicit
motive.
This was fundamentally about
appearances, about curating A
favorable impression for
significant international
visitors and.
Crucially, and this is where the
framing is so transparent, it
was not presented as some newly
conceived, comprehensive, long
term solution to the profound
and complex issue of
homelessness that San Francisco
faces.
No.
Nor was it framed as a sudden
aggressive crackdown on violent
crime or a new anti gang
operation.
It was simply and undeniably a
very public, very visible
cosmetic sweep the.
Governor laid bare the
operational reality and the
political narrative, and they
were refreshingly the same.
He was basically saying yes,
we're doing this because
important people are coming and
we want to look our no.
Hidden agenda, No
reinterpretation of facts.
It was quite simply a broom
being used as a broom for a
specific stated purpose.
Tidying up and.
This candor was largely mirrored
in the media framing across San
Francisco, which is what makes
it so distinctive for our
comparison, right?
Absolutely.
Major news outlets cutting
across various ideological
leanings almost universally
acknowledged that the cleanup
was precisely what Governor
Newsom had stated, a cosmetic
pre summit effort.
You saw headlines that directly
referenced the preparations for
APEC, right?
Often featuring images of
freshly scrubbed streets and
newly painted facades, Some
reports, in fact, even went a
step further, subtly or
sometimes overtly mocking the
sheer speed and efficiency with
which the city administration
could act when international
attention and dignitaries were
on the line.
Kind of.
Implying why can't you do this
all the time exactly.
That was the critical subtext.
Why couldn't such rapid,
concerted efforts be applied
more consistently to the city's
ongoing challenges when the
cameras weren't rolling?
But the.
Pivotal point as you noted is
that the reporting consistently
did not pretend this was a
deeper crackdown on violent
crime or some kind of sweeping
anti gang initiative.
The.
Conversation remained anchored
to the events, purpose, optics
for a global summit.
The broom in this very specific
public discourse was indeed
allowed to be just a broom A.
Tool wielded for a transparent,
stated purpose, tidying up for
an important event and.
This straightforwardness in the
narrative, the clear alignment
between action, stated motive
and media portrayal, provides a
compelling baseline for us to
compare against our next case
study, where the narrative
unfolded in a starkly different
manner.
This wasn't about a crisis, it
was about presentation.
That.
Remarkable level of
transparency.
That broom is just a broom
narrative truly sets the stage
for our next case because there
the framing could not have been
more dramatically different.
It highlights just how much the
context and the messenger can
alter the public's perception of
fundamentally similar actions.
OK.
So we're going next.
Let's now.
Pivot and Fast forward a bit in
our hypothetical timeline,
perhaps to August 2025.
Imagine for a moment former
President Donald Trump is back
in the White House from the Oval
Office.
He announces a series of
significant actions impacting
the nation's capital,
Washington, DC.
These actions involve 2
immediate and highly impactful
measures.
First, the federalization of the
DC Metropolitan Police
Department.
Whoa.
And 2nd.
The deployment of units from the
National Guard, right?
So let's unpack those actions,
because they carry profound
implications.
Federalizing the DC police means
placing the city's entire police
force, which is usually under
local civilian oversight,
directly under federal control
and the.
President can do that because DC
isn't a state.
Exactly because Washington, DC
falls under direct federal
jurisdiction, it's a federal
district.
This isn't just some routine
administrative shift.
It's a significant
centralization of power over law
enforcement in the capital and
the.
National Guard deployment.
Well, the National Guard is a
reserve military force, citizen
soldiers that can be mobilized
domestically.
Governors use them for
disasters, but the president can
also activate them for public
order issues, essentially
bringing military support into a
civilian urban environment.
So, taken together, these
actions signify a very
deliberate move to assert
strong, centralized federal
control over the capital's
public safety apparatus.
A very.
Strong move, yes.
And what?
Did this look like on the ground
in the streets and neighborhoods
of DC?
Early indications, and indeed
the rhetoric accompanying these
actions, pointed towards a clear
implementation of what's widely
known as a broken window
strategy.
Ah.
Broken Windows For listeners
perhaps unfamiliar, that's a
criminological theory famously
articulated by James Q Wilson
and George L Kelling back in the
1980s.
What's the?
Core idea the.
Core idea is that visible signs
of crime and disorder, things
like broken windows, graffiti,
public intoxication, loitering,
create an environment that
signals nobody cares.
And this lack of concern, the
theory goes, encourages more
serious violent crimes to
flourish.
So.
By cracking down aggressively on
the minor stuff if you prevent.
The Major Crimes, That's the
theory.
So.
In DC, under this new federal
oversight, the practical
application was swift and
visible.
You saw homeless encampments
much like those in San Francisco
being systematically dismantled,
their residents displaced,
right?
And a dramatic, highly visible
increase in police presence
throughout the city.
Officers enforcing what might
previously have been considered
minor infractions.
Like what?
Things like jaywalking, public
urination, fare evasion on
public transport, minor
vandalism, a targeted 0
tolerance focus on petty St.
level offenses.
The operational goal from this
perspective was to restore a
sense of strict order and
control to the city's public
spaces now.
This is where the narrative
surrounding these actions
begins.
Its dramatic, divergent from the
observable operational reality,
isn't it?
Absolutely.
The rhetoric employed by former
President Trump and his
administration was almost
entirely couched in terms of
taking back the capital.
Taking back that's loaded
language.
Very loaded, steeped in
implications of a city lost to
crime, chaos, urban decay, a
place needing forceful
reclamation.
This language was designed to
evoke a sense of urgency, danger
and righteous intervention.
But.
And this is a truly critical
counterfact that often gets lost
in the narrative.
Violent crime in DC was at that
point already down a significant
26% from the prior year down.
26% That fact alone immediately
raises A crucial question.
Why was the primary narrative a
war on violent crime when,
according to the available
statistics, crime was already on
a noticeable downward trend?
Right.
It suggests the chosen narrative
wasn't just reflecting the facts
on the ground.
Exactly.
It seems more like a politically
charged and compelling
justification designed to rally
a particular segment of support.
It's much harder to generate
public urgency or political
momentum by saying violent crime
is down, but we want to make the
streets even cleaner, declaring.
A war is far more impactful, and
this is precisely where the
media framing in DC becomes
incredibly complex,
multifaceted, and frankly,
profoundly divergent, unlike the
relatively singular, transparent
narrative we observed with
Governor Newsom in San Francisco
here.
We saw not one, but two vastly
different and intensely charged
frames emerge, each painting a
completely distinct picture of
the same operational actions.
OK.
Frame number one on.
One hand, a substantial portion
of the media coverage,
particularly from outlets
perhaps more aligned with the
administrations messaging or its
base, unequivocally framed these
actions as a righteous war on
violent crime.
Think.
About the impact of that
specific framing.
It's not just describing a
policy.
It paints A profoundly urgent,
high stakes, almost existential
picture.
It's no.
Longer just tidying up public
spaces or enforcing minor laws.
It's a battle for the soul of
the city, a necessary aggressive
intervention to protect citizens
from a pervasive and dangerous
threat, and.
That conjures immediate dramatic
imagery, right?
Yeah.
SWAT teams, Police chases SWAT.
Teams bursting through doors,
high speed police chases,
intense murder investigations
dominating the news cycle.
Maybe even a city under siege,
desperately needing rescue.
It creates an almost cinematic
sense of crisis.
Which then?
Justifies a strong, decisive
response.
Precisely this narrative
validates aggressive tactics as
essential.
It shifts the entire public
conversation from maybe
administrative cleanup or urban
management to a heroic, morally
justified battle.
OK.
But then there was a completely
different framing happening
simultaneously.
Exactly.
A completely different and
equally vocal wing of media
coverage, especially from civil
rights organizations, legal
advocacy groups like the ACLU,
and progressive news outlets,
presented A starkly contrasting
and deeply alarming narrative.
How do?
They describe it They.
Describe former President
Trump's move in far more
perilous terms, as a dangerous
precedent, A deliberate and
potentially permanent
militarized occupation of what
is significantly A majority
black city.
Militarized occupation.
That's strong language too.
Very.
Strong.
Their fear was palpable and
clearly articulated that this
wasn't an isolated incident or
just about DC, but rather a
blueprint, a trial run that
would subsequently be replicated
in other large, predominantly
Democratic leaning urban
strongholds across the country,
places like Chicago, Baltimore,
Oakland, Detroit.
So a fear of it spreading a
deep.
Fear and the language used by
these critics was
extraordinarily strong, drawing
explicit and historically loaded
parallels.
They didn't just disagree with
the policy, they characterized
it as an authoritarian federal
coup, an illegitimate usurpation
of local governance.
Wow.
Too cool, yes?
They didn't shy away from using
terms steeped in the darkest
chapters of history, with
critics comparing the actions
and rhetoric to Nazi tactics, to
Hitler's consolidation of power
and to fascist movements.
So.
Evoking really serious
historical warnings.
Absolutely.
This rhetoric aim to evoke a
sense of profound alarm, warning
of a slide into authoritarianism
and the suppression of civil
liberties, particularly for
minority communities who
historically bear the brunt of
aggressive policing strategies.
So the narratives weren't just
different, they were
diametrically opposed.
Totally.
Opposed Each designed to evoke a
powerful, specific emotional and
ideological response from their
respective audiences.
Here's.
Where it gets really interesting
and frankly quite perplexing.
How can the exact same set of
physical actions dismantling
homeless encampments, increasing
visible police presence,
targeting petty offenses,
federalizing a local police
force generates such profoundly
opposing, intensely charged
narratives?
It's.
Jarring, isn't it?
In.
San Francisco As we discussed,
the broom was simply a broom.
Its purpose was transparent,
acknowledged, and largely
accepted for what it was.
But in DC, these very same types
of operational actions were
instantly transformed, depending
on the framing, into either a
righteous, desperate war against
criminals or into the chilling
first steps of an authoritarian
takeover.
And.
What's profoundly and
constituously missing in the DC
context, from either side of the
media framing, is that plain,
unadorned broom narrative.
The.
One that was so readily present
and accepted in San Francisco.
Exactly.
There was no widespread public
discourse about simply cleaning
up for appearances in DC, even
though some of the physical
actions on the ground were quite
similar.
The political stakes and the
identity of the actor utterly
overshadowed any attempt at
operational candor.
Which?
Brings us to what you've termed
the asymmetry of honesty in
public discourse.
Yes.
And it is absolutely crucial to
understand that the asymmetry we
are highlighting here is not
about establishing some moral
equivalence between former
President Trump's political aims
and Governor Newsom's political
aims.
Right.
That's not the point here.
Those aims, as the sources
clearly indicate and as the
context suggests, were indeed
very different.
One centered on presenting an
international facade for a
specific event.
The other was couched in terms
of domestic control and public
order.
Despite underlying crime
statistics that complicated that
narrative, we are absolutely not
asserting that one set of
actions or their ultimate goals
are morally better or worse than
the other.
Our goal here is purely
analytical, purely.
Analytical.
Exactly the core of this
asymmetry, the critical point of
comparison for our deep dive,
lies specifically in how
candidly the press describes
their similar tactics, the
operational actions on the
ground with.
Governor Newsom in San
Francisco, the public was given
a remarkably plain,
straightforward truth.
It was openly stated and widely
reported as a cosmetic sweep,
tidying up for a visiting head
of state A.
Transparent, almost unapologetic
explanation.
The operational reality, what
was physically happening, and
the state of political narrative
were in this instance, largely
aligned in the public's
understanding, no.
Need for complex interpretation
The broom was openly
acknowledged as a tool for
tidiness, but with former.
President Trump's hypothetical
actions in DC, the very same
type of operational action,
clearing public spaces, moving
homeless populations, increasing
visible policing, essentially
what amounts to a large scale
urban sweep, is immediately
reframed.
Reframed in two wildly opposing
but equally loaded and
emotionally charged ways on one
side, it is presented as a
righteous, necessary crusade
against violent criminals,
implying A dire, uncontrollable
situation that demands drastic,
almost martial intervention.
Suggesting the capital is in
peril and only strong arm
tactics can save it, right?
And on the other side, it is
swiftly described as the ominous
first stage of a racially
targeted authoritarian program,
suggesting A darker, more
insidious motive aimed at
suppressing civil liberties,
disproportionately impacting
minority populations and
consolidating unchecked federal
power.
And what is consistently,
conspicuously, perhaps tellingly
absent in the public discourse
surrounding Trump's actions from
either perspective is that.
Neutral, plain broom narrative.
You would never hear a
widespread public statement or
media framing like the president
is simply cleaning up the city
for appearances.
The political overlay is too
thick, the implications too
significant.
And it's.
Really important to reinforce
this point, while the overall
scope, the political context and
the ultimate motives might
indeed differ significantly, 1
focused on international optics,
the other on domestic governance
and political messaging.
Operationally meaning the
physical actions on the ground
like.
Clearing public spaces, managing
homeless populations, increasing
visible policing and forcing
public order.
They were.
Similar enough to warrant this
direct comparison and how their
media framing unfolded.
This critical distinction
between the operational
similarities and the narrative
differences is what's key to
grasping the full picture it.
Really is.
It's about the form, not just
the content of how things are
presented, so.
If we connect this observation
to the bigger picture, it.
Highlights a profound and
ongoing challenge for an
informed citizenry, doesn't it?
When similar operational
actions, the concrete facts of
what is physically occurring,
are cloaked in such dramatically
different, often emotionally
charged and ideologically driven
narratives, it.
Becomes incredibly difficult for
the public to discern what is
truly happening on the ground
versus what story is being
skillfully crafted for political
or persuasive purposes it.
Actively demands a significantly
higher level of critical
engagement, media literacy, and
independent thought from each of
us.
We are constantly swimming
through layers of interpretation
and it takes deliberate effort
to reach the bedrock of
operational fact.
And that leads us directly to
the crucial, perhaps most
practical question of our deep
dive today.
Why does framing matter so much?
And how does it actually shades
not just our opinions, but our
very public imagination and our
understanding of events, often
in an almost unconscious level?
Well.
As we've explored, framing
profoundly effects what the
public imagines is taking place.
Let's reiterate those stark
examples because they truly
capture for this phenomenon.
When you hear the phrase war on
violent crime, your mind
immediately conjures very
specific, often dramatic and
visceral images.
You might envision highly
trained SWAT teams bursting
through doors, high speed police
chases tearing through urban
streets.
Intense murder trials dominating
the news, or grizzled detectives
pouring over crime scenes.
It's a high octane, almost
cinematic vision of an urban
landscape under siege, requiring
drastic, often aggressive
intervention.
Your heart rate might even pick
up a little.
Right on the absolute flip side,
when you hear cleaning the
streets for a visitor, the
images that spontaneously spring
to mind are entirely different,
often far more mundane and
administrative.
You might picture city workers
in bright vests with industrial
power washers.
Dedicated individuals scrubbing
away graffiti, the rhythmic hum
of a street sweeper or tense
being carefully, sometimes
awkwardly, dismantled and moved.
These are two completely
distinct sets of mental pictures
evoking entirely different
emotional and intellectual
responses.
The.
Crucial insight here, and it
absolutely bears repeating
because it's so central to
understanding framing, is that
both of these narrative frames,
the dramatic war on violent
crime and the more prosaic
cleaning for a visitor, could in
fact involve the exact same
physical operations on the
ground.
Yes.
The actual acts of
systematically dismantling
homeless encampments, deploying
increased police patrols in
specific areas, or rigorously
enforcing minor infractions of
public order could be present
and central to both scenarios.
The.
Fundamental difference.
The defining factor that shapes
public perception is solely in
the frame.
Applied to those operations,
it's.
About the meaning, the urgency,
the moral justification, and the
symbolic weight that the
narrative assigns to those
actions, not necessarily the
actions themselves.
The physical reality can be
constant while the perceived
reality shifts dramatically
based on the words used to
describe it so.
Given all this, what does this
all mean for you, our dedicated
listener, as a citizen trying to
navigate the daily overwhelming
influx of information from news
outlets, social media, political
rhetoric?
Why is it so profoundly
important for each of us to
consciously separate operational
reality from the political
narrative?
It's not just an academic
exercise, it's a vital skill for
democratic engagement,
understanding.
This distinction is absolutely
vital because it empowers you to
dissect the news more
effectively to become a more
critical and discerning consumer
of information rather than a
passive recipient it.
Actively helps citizens separate
2 very different layers of
information.
First, there's the operational
reality.
That is what is physically
happening, the concrete
observable actions being taken
on the ground, the verifiable
facts and.
Second, there's the political
narrative, which is the story
being told about those actions,
a story that is almost always
meticulously designed to
persuade you, to influence your
opinion, to rally support for a
particular agenda, or to
demonize an opponent.
When?
You can consciously make that
crucial separation when you can
ask yourself, OK, what is
actually happening here and what
story is being told about it,
OK, you become a far more
discerning and ultimately a far
more informed citizen, less
susceptible to manipulation and
this.
Analytical lens isn't just for
parsing political news either,
right?
Not.
At all.
Both the San Francisco and
Washington examples are, at
their core, compelling
illustrations of performances
layered over public policy.
They are fundamentally about
making a city appear a certain
way to specific targeted
audiences, whether.
Those audiences are foreign
dignitaries and global investors
or domestic voters and a
political base.
It's about optics, symbolism,
and the powerful messages those
optics convey.
And while the specific aims of
Governor Newsom and former
President Trump may differ
significantly in their broader
political contexts, it's
imperative to acknowledge that
both types of operations
inevitably disrupt lives.
Absolutely the lives of the
homeless who are displaced, the
daily routines of residents who
encounter increased policing,
the economic realities for local
businesses and.
Both types of operations also
convey messages that extend far
beyond the specific block, where
a cluster of tents might be
taken down or a sidewalk power
washed.
They send signals about who
belongs, who controls public
space, and what type of order is
prioritized.
So the.
Overarching point of this deep
dive isn't to declare moral
equivalence between the two
scenarios.
Definitely not.
Their underlying intentions,
broader context and long term
impacts are indeed quite
different.
And that's a conversation for
another time.
Instead, our purpose today has
been to understand the mechanics
of how information is presented
to us, how it is framed, and how
that framing profoundly shapes
our understanding.
Because.
Knowledge is most valuable when
it is not just absorbed, but
truly understood and consciously
applied.
And this kind of critical
thinking, the ability to look
past the rhetoric and identify
the operational facts, to
distinguish between the broom
and the narrative about the
broom, is absolutely essential.
In a world increasingly
saturated with information, much
of it presented with a specific
agenda, it helps.
You build more accurate picture
of reality rather than one
solely colored by persuades of
narratives.
So as we wrap up this
eliminating deep dive, let's
briefly recap our core insight,
the truly incredible, often
underestimated power of framing
and the often present asymmetry
in how similar operational
actions are described in public
discourse.
Remember, an informed
electorate, one capable of
making sound decisions about his
leaders and its future, truly
relies on descriptive honesty.
Not just from those who report
the news, but ideally from the
political figures themselves to
Given.
Everything we've unpacked today
about the plane broom versus the
highly loaded narratives.
Here's a thought for you, our
listener.
How about you approach the news
differently this week?
When?
You encounter reports about
public actions, particularly
those undertaken by political
figures.
What other sweeps or actions
might be happening around us
that are being obscured or
amplified by their framing are
their actions?
Being portrayed as emergencies
when they are operationally
maybe more routine, or
conversely, actions being
downplayed when their
operational reality is far more
significant.
And what would it truly take for
us as citizens to consistently
demand that plain broom
narrative, that straightforward,
unvarnished description of
operational reality, no matter
who is wielding the broom, no
matter what their political
affiliation or stated motive?
It's a big.
Question it.
Is I strongly encourage you to
keep an active eye out for how
similar events or policies are
reported across different media
outlets.
Don't just settle for one
perspective, actively seek out
multiple angles.
Try to.
Discern the underlying
operational actions, the
verifiable facts from the
narratives being intentionally
built around them.
Pay.
Attention to the language used,
the imagery presented, the
emotions evoked.
You might be surprised and
empowered by what you discover
about the pervasive, often
subtle, power of framing and
shaping our collective
understanding of the world
around us.
Thank.
You for joining us on this deep
dive into the fascinating and
crucially important world of
framing and perception.
We hope it gives you a powerful
new lens through which to view
the news and indeed the entire
political landscape.
Until next time, keep digging
deeper.